[Music]
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I want to talk about
everyone's favorite super baby Jack Jack
and explain and rank his seventeen
Powers if you new here I do regular
Pixar and superhero videos Plus
giveaways to enter my latest giveaway
make sure you're a subscriber watch my
video and let me know your top three
Jack Jack powers some spoilers ahead for
Jack Jack scene so take care if you
haven't seen Incredibles 2 yet and
remember you can add this video to your
watch later playlist we only see his
powers of electro Kinesis very briefly
and Incredibles 2 when Jack Jack sneezes
after mr. incredible discovers Jack
Jack's powers for the first time we see
a brief Lightning effect around the
super-powered baby suggesting he can
summon electricity in fact it reminds me
a bit of Thor's lightning powers in the
MCU after Syndrome kidnap Jack Jack in
the first movie the baby transformed
into metal dragging the villain down and
throwing him off balance Jack Jack's
levitation powers are a fun spectacle
we've seen in the short Jack Jack Attack
and Incredibles - and it's something he
appears to be able to control quite well
associated with this power is the
ability to reverse gravity selectively
for example in the short while Jack Jack
hangs upside down on the ceiling
he maintains his position but allows the
milk from his bottle to fall on Sakaki
when manifesting his powers Jack Jack
displays various degrees of super
strength durability and resistance
during the raccoon fight he physically
wrestles kicks and smacks the creature
across the yard and he also picks up and
throws garden furniture with ease in
Jack Jack Attack he was able to chew his
way through a wooden play pen there
wasn't any sign of wood left over either
suggesting that Jack Jack's body can
even cope with digesting organic matter
like wood his skin is also pretty damage
resistant - because he can withstand
fighting with the raccoon and even
turning himself on fire and that ability
to burst into flames is pretty cool and
what he touches can also catch fire - he
used this power against syndrome in the
first movie but it's something that
often seems to be triggered by emotion
it would definitely be good to see him
learn to harness the ability and even
potentially throw fireballs and then the
cool power Jack Jack
Incredibles 2 is the ability to rocket
jump or blast off and that often seems
to be brought on by a sneeze Jack Jack
also has a sort of elasticity similar to
his mother where he can stretch his body
for example when he's attacked by the
raccoon and this could well be an
important part of his seeming
invulnerability there's an interesting
moment in the incredible when after
escaping from the hypnotize supers at
the house the Parr children are feeling
unsure about how to go forward
Jack Jack levitates rotates and at the
same time performs a weird reality
distortion effect that warps and wobbles
of space inside the car this reminds the
kids that they have a secret weapon
they're highly super-powered baby
brother
and that kick starts them into action
seeing Jack Jack create multiple copies
of himself is pretty awesome this is a
useful skill to have against an opponent
and we see this when Jack Jack attacks
the raccoon and it reminds me somewhat
of Agent Smith from the matrix
Jack Jack also self multiplies at Edna's
house and while he's there we also get
to see his power of mimicry he can not
only make himself look like the feisty
fashion designer but he can also imitate
her physical expressions
Jack Jack used his ability to
shape-shift into a demon to ferociously
good effect against syndrome as the
infant transformed he gets red skin
longer nails and sharper teeth plus his
muscles expand giving him increased
strength and maneuverability which he
uses to pull out syndromes hair and
attack his rocket boots
the sequel also shows Jack Jack
transforming into a demon on multiple
occasions and suggests this power is
often triggered when the toddler gets
angry for example when he's denied a
cookie it's a pretty funny moment and
Incredibles 2 and Jack Jack grows into a
giant baby bursting out of an event
where he and his siblings were hiding he
also then smashes and runs through a
series of metal walls in a moment that
reminded me of juggernaut in x-men 3 of
course with ant-man and the wasp out
this year as well I couldn't help but
also think of giant man Jack Jack's
ability to teleport is an incredibly
useful one that first manifested in Jack
Jack Attack this is the first power he
ever displayed and happened just after
Corey put on some classical music by
Mozart the Parr family had always
assumed that Jack Jack was normal but
just after Corey
on some Mozart jack-jack seems to perk
up and his eyes dilate and in the next
few seconds his powers kick into action
it seems like it was Mozart that
unlocked Jack Jack's latent superpowers
because his car he says to Helen AOL
remotes had to play rain cleats to make
him smarter because leading experts say
Mozart makes baby smart phasing through
solid objects like walls and windows is
another incredibly useful skill as it
means Jack Jack isn't really constrained
by any physical boundaries Corey
witnessed this to hilarious effect in
Jack Jack Attack and we also see him use
this in Incredibles too not only can
Jack Jack teleport between physical
locations but he can also travel to
other dimensions and once there he can
still even communicate with our own
dimension by the way the other dimension
scene is a fantastic easter egg to the
classic horror movie poltergeist which I
talk more about in my Easter eggs video
there's a link for that at the end of
this video and in the video description
we first get a taste of Jack Jack's
telekinetic powers when during the
raccoon scene he uses his mind to raise
the trashcan lid off the floor and it's
Jack Jack who ultimately breaks the
hypnotic spell cast on Elastigirl when
he telekinetically removes her goggles
Jack Jack's telekinesis is a new ability
that we see for the first time in the
sequel and this Power has been wielded
by some of the most powerful heroes on
screen think Jean Grey from the x-men
and 11 from stranger things
Jack Jack 17 powers are all fantastic so
deciding on my favorite was tough but
his laser vision and how he uses it in
the racoon scene is pretty amazing we
did see the laser eyes for the first
time in Jack Jack Attack where khari
used a hand mirror to deflect the Rays
however one of the funniest moments in
Incredibles 2 has to be when Bob turns
Jack Jack into a kind of baby laser gun
just demonstrating don't firing the baby
around the house you understand now what
are your three favorite Jack Jack powers
and what would you like to see him do if
there's another sequel let me know what
you think and don't forget to subscribe
and turn on notifications to enter my
Incredibles giveaway tap the link here
to watch the top 30 Easter eggs you
missed in Incredibles 2 or check out my
full Pixar playlist if you enjoyed this
alike is really appreciated and you can
tweet me at Jan underscore Gilbert near
Incredibles 2 videos are on the way plus
Jurassic world 2 next week thanks for
watching and see you next time you PK
movie lovers